you know I'm of the belief that every
movie has a lesson the lesson in Evil
Dead is simple demonically possessed
[ __ ] and nail guns they do not mix I
mean it mix for her but not for anyone
else in the room anyone else in the room
it's a bad day evil day so Evil Dead is
a remake of the old Evil Dead movie the
story of Evil Dead is five people go to
this cabin and they find a little creepy
trapdoor on the ground and they find a
book down there and rating from the book
is going to unleash evil it sound
familiar yes it does because cabin in
the woods is still relevant and I will
reference it in most any horror movie
review that I do but they do not unleash
the evil of zombified Payne worshiping
back was idiots now they unleash this
demon that starts possessing them and
starts doing really messed-up [ __ ] to
them they probably would have been
better off with the Buckner's if I'm
being completely honest now I knew going
into this movie this movie served one
purpose to take horror movies back to
what horror movies were in the 80s
without all the CGI use props and gore
and all that good [ __ ] and for the most
part Evil Dead does do what it's set out
to do I'm gonna touch on this right now
because it's the point of the movie Evil
Dead has some really disturbing imagery
is it scary not really I wish the movie
was scarier than it was disturbingly
gory yeah but it's not like torture porn
you know I saw in hostile words like I'm
torturing you and that's the whole
gimmick of the movie it's not like that
it is different than that really bad
[ __ ] happens to these people like to the
point where you reflect on other horror
movies and you're like yeah you really
had it easy you know those people that
go to the priest and they're like look
my wife's really freaked out I'm pretty
sure I saw a little baby's arm in the
closet and tried to grab my face that's
all the kids about it and it's really
bad you know we can barely sleep you
know we can barely sleep because the tv
turns on at night and that's not good we
need you can you please exercise our
house I just want this priests to be
like wow did you go to a crickety cabin
in the woods I mean did you experience
that [ __ ] because I'm pretty sure if
your pretty little wife is still walking
around with her face you guys are gonna
get through it
alright you entitled first world problem
douchebag yeah go back home so sprinkle
and holy water on your TV and just get
over it yeah these people get brutalized
pretty bad in this movie are the people
good actors ain't no for what they are
it's the dialogue force for the most
part the intro all the characters like
hey man what's up man you're my best
friend ever how's your girlfriend right
there because we need to establish that
for the audience alright I'm gonna go
talk to my sister who I'm estranged from
but I need to tell her that
the audience knows exactly where
everyone stands in the intro of this
movie but I get it the movie like the
issue can't spend all your time on
character build-up because we're here to
watch them all die we're not here to
watch people die that we actually care
about we're here to watch people get
brutalized that we don't give a [ __ ]
about they do look a job at illustrating
why these people are in this cabin and
why they're not leaving movies like this
that one person is always like this is
freaking me out I want to go and all the
friends will like look calm down and
look at a friend you are with your
friends but the relationship I have with
my friends are like if someone is like I
don't want to be here this is scaring me
I probably think they're out of their
minds and crazy and overreacting but we
will go in Evil Dead they're all in this
cabin because this one chick has to
detox because she's a drug addict
someone she starts freaking out he's
like there's something in the woods or
like some people just can't handle detox
I will never for the life of me know why
this guy read this book I mean you're an
educated man you're not like a 16 year
old stumbling across the hidden works of
Stephenie Meyer's some [ __ ] not like the
book said j.r.r tolkien the first
edition this must be read right now it's
a book with a book cover made of human
flesh containing satanic imagery why the
[ __ ] would you read that [ __ ] in the end
Evil Dead did what it set out to do is a
groundbreaking no does it throwback to
horror movies of the 80s yes it does it
doesn't overly CGI it uses props and
that's all cool I will say for me Evil
Dead was a good time no alcohol required
if you're a gore hound really looking
forward to a movie that brings it back
to the horror movies of the 80s mark it
up to a buy it on blu-ray for you so
have you seen Evil Dead have you seen
the original have you seen the new one
do you like the original do you like the
new one do you think the new one
captures what the original was do you
think it's a good ol much in the
original or do you think this is another
[ __ ] remake whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you